follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the Lange focused channel and my name is
Paul a couple of months back I made a
video about whether English is really a
Germanic language or not and I made the
rather controversial statement that in a
sense English is a hybrid language
because so much of its vocabulary comes
from the Romance languages and from
other languages that statement was
controversial because the core of
English is indeed Germanic and it is
actually possible to speak English with
mostly or even entirely Germanic words
for example instead of saying literature
which is a Romance word you could say
book craft or instead of saying ancestor
you could say for kin it's not exactly
easy to speak that way all the time but
it is possible there is actually a
movement to create and to promote a new
form of English like this that stripped
of all of its non Germanic influences so
that English would basically become the
language of would have been if it had
not been influenced by Romance languages
and by Greek and others some people
refer to this strictly Germanic form of
English as English because it's supposed
to take English back to its anglo-saxon
roots English is a form of English
linguistic purism English seeks to
achieve the Germanic purity of English
in a few different ways first by
choosing existing Germanic words rather
than the romance equivalent to by
reviving obsolete Germanic words 3 by
adopting words from Old English or other
Germanic languages 4 by creating new
words based on Old English or other
germanic roots so take this simple
sentence the man forgot his rain shade
at home what do you think rain shade
means something that provides shade from
the rain if you guessed umbrella that's
right
rain shade is a new word created from
rain and shade and it's based on the
word Sun Shade umbrella is a loanword
from Italian umbrella all of the other
words in this sentence are regular
English words of Germanic origin and you
probably noticed that the words are not
changed into Old English they're all in
modern English just without the non
Germanic elements another example I on
look the man since he's very isn't now
here's the original sentence I wrote in
standard English I respect the man
because he's very industrious
on look comes from Old English on Lake
to observe or regard but it seems the
sense has been extended to mean regard
positively or respect now why did I
change the word because well because the
cause part of because is of romance
origin since is just a Germanic
alternative to because it is a real
English word which is still used in some
dialects of northern England and I
believe also in Scotland and of course
when I speak of that man who's very
isn't I'm referring to a name known show
player I've seen on the Farseer hmm a
name known show player I've seen on the
Farseer here's the original phrase in
standard English a famous actor I've
seen on the television name known is a
newly a shapen word that comes from name
and known markedly and show player is
another melding of tuba standing words
and Farseer
is a likeness of the German word fanzine
in everyday talk we deal with a lot of
Germanic words but for some under warps
like whit ship we deal with many more
Outland words in 1989 author Paul
Anderson for late a well-known RIT named
unclipped dish beholding which means
atomic theory in thoroughly Germanic
English without any Outland words let's
take a look at some of that RIT for most
of its being
mankind did not know what things are
made of but could only guess with the
growth of world can we began to learn
and today we have a beholding of stuff
and work that watching bears out both in
the work stead and in daily life being
is used instead of existence world ken
means physics
beholding means Theory stuff I believe
means matter work I think means energy
and works Ted means work place the
underlying kinds of stuff are the first
stuffs which linked together in sundry
ways to give rise to the rest formerly
we knew of 92 for stuffs from water
stuff the lightest and barest
to e mere stuff the heaviest first
stuffs are elements sundry means various
this is a regular English word it's just
less common than various water stuff
means hydrogen barrassed means simplest
and aamir stuff means uranium in my wind
this seems like English but somewhat
weird English English is interesting
because by trying to read it or use it
we get a sense of just how
much we normally rely on non Germanic
vocabulary when we speak English
on the other hand you learned that it is
possible to speak English without any
non Germanic words if you're willing to
use some archaic vocabulary or new
vocabulary based on Germanic roots
the grammar is the same so it's mainly a
matter of consciously substituting
different vocabulary so the question of
the day what do you think of linguistic
purism like English do you think there's
any reason to remove foreign influences
from a language or do you see those
foreign influences as just part of the
languages development let us know in the
comments down below you can find out
more about English at English wiki accom
be sure to follow length focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and I'd
like to say thank you to all of my
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here for their monthly pledges
thank you for watching and have a lovely
day
[Music]